[Music]
on this Thursday night new alarm in
Quebec that provinces coronavirus
caseload climbs by a thousand
we need everyone to come and help out
who is answering the urgent cries for
help us the new outbreak at a huge oil
sands camp in Alberta why thousands in
Michigan are defying stay-at-home orders
what could a safe and slow reopening of
the economy really look like this
shutdown has become one of total
insanity antibody tests under scrutiny
the hope they could offer and the
lingering questions to and where one
small step and lead when comparing mark
a salute to captain Thomas Moore and his
remarkable fundraising
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with the crisis in many
long-term care homes in this country as
they struggle to contain outbreaks of
kovat 19 there are indications the
number of deaths continues to be
underreported especially in Quebec and
Ontario today overall Quebec recorded
its Binga biggest single-day spike in
deaths the number of people who died in
Quebec jumped by 143 today that brings
the total to 630 an increase in part due
to a change in the way deaths are
counted and a closer look at the causes
of death among them is a 44 year old
doctor the first health care worker in
Quebec to die of kovat 19 across the
country there are some big regional
differences 997 new cases in Quebec 514
in Ontario 162 new cases in Alberta that
of course reflects only the people who
have been tested more than 1100 people
in Canada are now known to have died
roughly half the deaths are in long-term
care homes if the measure of a society
is in how it cares for its most
vulnerable this pandemic has revealed
the [ __ ] in our armor Quebec Premier
put out a call for help in the care
homes about 2,000 doctors have responded
Mike Armstrong explains why help is
needed so urgently it's likely to look
strange but in the coming days there may
be military vehicles in front of Quebec
seniors residences with a critical staff
shortage network-wide
a patient's rights advocate says
soldiers should be stepping in we need
everyone well intended to come in help
out of course Quebec has put out an
urgent appeal for help from anyone with
health care experience but it's still
struggling with more and more workers
off with kovat 19 off as a precaution or
off after burnout we need thousands and
thousands of people not just a few
hundreds
Quebec official request for military
help was sent to Ottawa Wednesday night
exactly when soldiers could hit the
ground or what they be doing is still
being negotiated we don't have details
to offer at this moment on personnel or
tasks because those need to be worked
out but they are being worked out right
now across the country about half of all
kovat 19 deaths have been in long-term
care facilities Rebecca is the only
province to ask for military help so far
but it's not the only one struggling
well we we haven't asked as of yet but
that we everything's on the table
Canada's premiers and Prime Minister
have a conference call Thursday night
Justin Trudeau says the issue of
long-term care facilities is on the
agenda it is impossible to imagine the
anguish families and indeed our elders
are going through in this situation
there is just so much fear so much
uncertainty now one of the measures
Quebec is bringing in to supplement
staffing has angered workers and
long-term care facilities and many
members of the public the province
negotiated a deal with specialists
doctors with elective surgeries on hold
they're not working well that deal would
pay them to work in seniors residences
about two hundred and eleven dollars an
hour that's in line with what they
normally be paid but several times more
than the nurses and orderlies they'd be
working alongside doing the same duties
one of the orderlies unions calls it
insulting my carbs from Global News
Montreal anyone who lives in close
quarters with others is at risk and that
includes correctional facilities now an
inmate NBC has died the first death
linked to a federal facility
Correctional Service Canada says the
inmate from the mission institution bc's
Fraser Valley died in hospital yesterday
from an apparent complication related to
Kovac 19:00 the medium security facility
has a serious outbreak 54 inmates and at
least eight workers there have tested
positive there's also been an outbreak
at an Alberta based oil sands mine where
workers live in extremely close quarters
twelve people who work at the curl Lake
project which is about 70 kilometres
north of Fort McMurray
Berta have contracted the virus Imperial
which owns the project in partnership
with ExxonMobil says it's enforced daily
screenings of staff and physical
distancing at work but thousands of
people work there and many fly in and
out of the camp as Heather your ex west
reports health officials are working to
contain the outbreak but shutting down
the operation isn't an option the work
camp at curl Lake is designed to house
thousands they fly in from all over the
country to work in the oil sands now
Alberta Health officials say some of
those workers have tested positive for
coffee 19 Alberta Health Services
continues to work closely with the
company to implement outbreak procedures
at the site and to minimize any risk of
transmission Imperial says it's enhanced
cleaning protocols and has been
screening employees for symptoms since
mid-march but even with physical
distancing rules in place the virus has
spread keep in mind a lot of these
people don't they don't even Ivan from
Alberta they get on planes they fly back
to Newfoundland or the Maritimes or BC
the Alberta Federation of Labor is
calling on the provincial government to
limit the number of people at the camp
to the minimum number required low oil
prices have already led to a decrease in
the number of workers here but experts
warn shutting down projects completely
would be more complicated it would take
weeks at least to plan and probably a
month to implement all the shutdown
procedures to properly do it and it
would take a lot of people not the
people who are there normally to run it
but a bunch of contractors to come in to
shut the place down properly this is not
something that we can take lightly the
the enormous economic long-term risk of
simply by Fiat shutting down sagte
projects in particular could be
devastating to the province for years to
come
and so the province is working with the
company to mitigate the risks hoping to
contain this outbreak before anyone else
gets sick Heather your ex west global
news Calgary the federal government is
expanding the criteria for the Canada
emergency business account allowing more
companies to qualify for loans more than
one hundred and ninety five thousand
loans worth 7.5 billion dollars have
been approve
so far but some businesses didn't
qualify so the threshold has been
expanded to include businesses that
spent a minimum of $20,000 and up to a
maximum of one and a half million
dollars in 2019 they'll be able to
access interest-free loans of up to
$40,000 the Prime Minister promises a
program to help small businesses pay
their rent says that's coming in the
coming days and he was working with the
provinces on that and the supply of
personal protective equipment is still
being worked on the federal government
said today just under 300 million
surgical masks have now been ordered and
more than 17 million have already been
delivered of the hundred and forty five
million n95 respirators ordered roughly
800 thousand have arrived and 1.1
million are expected to reach provinces
and territories this week the government
says more than 14 million pairs of
gloves have reached those in need
another 900,000 are on the way and it
says orders have been finalized for up
to 30,000 life-saving ventilators
there's intense pressure in some
American States especially Michigan to
end the lockdown and get people back to
work
president Donald Trump has been hinting
at that yesterday he mused about opening
the US Canada border to non-essential
travel sooner rather than later
the u.s. though is still the epicenter
of the pandemic and today Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau said a significant amount
of time is still needed before the two
countries can talk about loosening any
restrictions Jackson prosecco reports on
the pressure President Trump is under to
reopen the economy even as the death
toll there climbs an anonymous tip led
authorities to a New Jersey nursing home
where the bodies of 17 residents were
found piled in a tiny morgue as kovat 19
continues its deadly march across the
u.s. the staggering toll shows no sign
of slowing more than 2,400 people died
in the past 24 hours New York LA and
Washington extended stay at home orders
until mid-may ordering residents to wear
masks in public but the White House
insists the time is right to decide how
to reopen businesses and restart the US
economy my administration is issuing new
federal guideline
that will allow governor's to take a
phased and deliberate approach to
reopening their individual states a
crippled nation is divided over what to
do in Michigan people flooded the
streets Wednesday protesting strict
stay-at-home orders the mayor of Las
Vegas demanded businesses be allowed to
return to normal immediately this
shutdown
has become one of total insanity in my
opinion
health officials insist it's still too
soon for that next step
they want to see weeks of declines in
deaths and hospitalizations and say more
testing is needed to allow even a
gradual reopening of society the
capability of being able to test
identify isolate get someone who's
infected out of circulation even if the
White House succeeds in convincing
states to loosen restrictions it's not
clear the public will be willing to
return to daily life especially as
officials warn that anything close to
normal won't be possible until there's a
vaccine available the White House
guidelines released late this afternoon
essentially leave things up to the
governor's to decide what's best for
their individual states they're told to
monitor 14 day trends to see if there's
decline in case numbers and
hospitalizations they have to make sure
their hospitals have room for a surge if
case numbers start to rebound most
notably though Donna there is no
suggestion that they implement wide
broad-based testing as the health
experts have recommended Donna Jackson
cross Co in Washington thanks the speed
and the scale of job losses in the u.s.
is without precedent 5.2 million
Americans filed for applications for
unemployment benefits just last week and
that means a staggering 22 million
people have lost their jobs in the past
month roughly 13.5 percent of Americans
are now out of work the United States
has not seen this level of job loss
since the Great Depression some places
in Europe are gradually beginning to
reopen coming up why things may never
get completely
back to normal
Singapore is a cautionary tale it seemed
to have the coronavirus under control
after aggressive screening of travelers
testing and quarantines but now a new
outbreak is underway
Singapore reported seven hundred and
twenty eight new cases the biggest daily
jump most of them are linked to cramped
dormitories where low paid migrant
workers live Singapore has imposed a
partial lockdown until May 4th and made
it mandatory for people to wear masks
outside their homes japan's Prime
Minister expanded a state of emergency
to cover the entire country the measure
takes effect Friday and lasts until May
6th every Japanese citizen will also
receive cash payments of nearly $1,000
Japan has more than 9,000 Kovach 19
cases now and about 200 deaths Germany
is one of the countries set to begin
slowly easing some restrictions some
schools will reopen in early May but
bars restaurants theaters and religious
services will remain closed indefinitely
bans on large public events including
soccer matches will remain until at
least August 31st Chancellor Angela
Merkel says physical distancing is still
required and masks in public are
recommended but not mandatory getting
back to normal is what we all crave of
course but easing the restrictions is
just not wise as long as there is still
no treatment and no vaccine for this
virus yet plans are being made in Canada
to slowly begin to tweak the new normal
and ease some parts of the economy back
into business tempered by the worry it
could allow Kovan 19 to return as strong
as ever
Eric Sorenson explains for one month
Canadian businesses increasingly shut
down now the first pivot towards
reopening in Saskatchewan tentative
plans to allow certain businesses to
open up with distancing measures as
already practiced at grocery stores as
other businesses may be allowed to
reopen they will be expected to adopt
similar practices Saskatchewan though is
not Ontario or Quebec large provinces
with continuing outbreaks of kovat 19
some of the biggest employers in the
country are hurting but the last thing
they want is a hasty return to normal I
think
his threat to us today aside from the
virus is a false restart of the economy
we cannot afford what some would call it
W in our recovery where we have a second
shutdown the Europeans have been through
the worst and offer a possible glimpse
into our future this store in Rome
demonstrably disinfecting before opening
up others take the temperature of
customers in Germany they're measuring
off safe distances in schools and shops
and in Denmark elementary kids went back
to school this week
but that doesn't Herald a return to
normal business over here think major
league sports perhaps made-for-tv
competition but they're not going to
fill the stands the usual attractions
are not coming soon to a theater near
you or any place where crowds normally
gathered keep in mind we've seen the
economy shrink by 5 percent in the first
quarter and it would have been more but
for Ottawa stimulus and looking to the
second quarter it's expected the economy
will contract 23 percent on an
annualized basis that suggests a lot of
businesses will remain shuttered or that
reopening won't mean wide open we're
gonna still have containment around how
many people are allowed to in stores at
a time even after we have a vaccine I
still think that there could be some
psychological scarring from the current
environment for now the business and
epidemiological experts are in sync
don't let a second Kovan wave be a big
wave that we would be able to deal with
it without having to shut everything
down again that's the last thing we want
to do is release everything and then
bring it all back what would be worse
than the current economic pain is if it
achieves nothing Eric Sorensen Global
News Toronto
still ahead why antibody tests for Koba
19 may not be a game-changer
one of the greatest hopes for easing our
way out of our bubbles is antibody tests
blood tests that reveal whether we've
had Kovac 19 perhaps with no symptoms
that might mean we're immune and can
safely re-enter the workforce there are
dozens of antibody tests on the market
now but no government is using them
widely as crystal commencing explains
that's because what they can tell us for
certain is still unclear people are
clamoring to get these uncomfortable
nasal and throat swabs if the virus is
active in your body the genetic makeup
should show up if you've recovered
antibodies should be in your blood I saw
that there was a test for antibodies it
was a very simple test dr. gene
Carruthers is a cosmetic surgeon in
British Columbia this Canadian company
and an antibody test caught her eye
something that world's very interested
in is getting Canadians back into their
real world but safely dr. Caruthers
along with her colleagues wrote to
Canada's health minister advocating for
B tnx Health Canada has not approved the
test it's also not approved in the US
either but it is being sold under the
emergency use act in Europe the company
has a c e marking meaning it meets
european union requirements but that is
not an approval our applications right
now in canada are our sales for for
europe in the US this is to laboratories
and to healthcare professionals BTN x
CFO Mitch Pitt away says orders shipped
to the UK or for independent evaluations
UK Prime Minister Boris Johnson called
these types of tests a game-changer in
mid-march saying they'd be available
soon but the tests failed under scrutiny
the UK government is not currently using
any antibody tests the World Health
Organization is examining a number of
different tests including the antibody
test from BT NX notice this is of any
value of if actually it's not measuring
what it says it needs to measure so you
has to do a full evaluation getting an
accurate antibody test is complicated
because people will have different
levels of immunity and it isn't known
how long it lasts given the severity the
situation it makes complete sense but
agencies like Health Canada are doing
their due diligence that leaves us with
swab test to determine active cases of
the virus crystal the Manson Global News
London
from blow-drying your nostrils to
drinking tea next the myths about cures
for kovat 19
since this pandemic began Global News
has been taking York Ovid 19 questions
to the experts lately people have been
asking about claims health products and
home remedies might be able to fight the
virus so our jet sample asked experts to
separate fact from fiction this online
video allegedly produced by a doctor
claims to have found a cure for kovat 19
by simply breathing in hot air it notes
the corona virus SARS was killed by
temperatures of 56 degrees Celsius so it
suggests blasting a hair dryer up your
nose take slow deep breaths the method
was even promoted by a government
official in Florida as a treatment
option for those without medical
insurance it's essentially goofy and it
did to me too but it works but health
experts don't agree that sounds like a
very dangerous thing to do you might you
might dry out or even burn the very very
sensitive membranes that are actually
there in your nose social media is full
of questionable claims ways to protect
against kovat 19 from using sunlight to
gargling vinegar to drinking warm water
every 15 minutes completely untrue and
not based on any science whatsoever the
sun's UVC rays can kill some corona
viruses but only at concentrated levels
produced by machines like this one used
to sterilize smartphones at Toronto
hospitals and while drinking water won't
wash out the virus it does help to stay
hydrated the Twittersphere is also
teaming with tips on immune boosting
supplements and vitamins such as
echinacea and vitamin C so there isn't a
specific supplement or medication that's
going to make you immune or even proven
to decrease the likelihood that you'll
acquire the virus an Ontario company
even received this warning from American
authorities after claiming a hirable t
works well against coronavirus
infections but not all home remedies are
hopeless some studies for example have
shown that gargling with an antiseptic
like mouthwash might help against a
respiratory infection and of course
scientists are just beginning to
study what if anything works against
coab in nineteen in the meantime
regardless of the product or the promise
they're asking everyone to do their
research and make sure there aren't any
negative side effects Donna just simple
in Toronto thanks and that is global
national for this Thursday I'm donor
Friesen we didn't want to leave you
tonight before we updated you on the
retired British Captain Thomas More
he's the ninety nine year old who has
now reached his goal of 100 laps of his
garden before his 100th birthday inches
to go there he is
congratulations there he is a military
guard of honor lined his route today
he's now raised an astonishing 15
million pounds far surpassing his goal
of 1,000 pounds all of it going to those
on the front lines of the British
National Health Service and he's not
stopping we salute you too captain Moore
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]